E
SMOOTH GROUND AHEAD.
>> NOW THE FOUNDER EXECUTIVE
CHAIRMAN OF WEST, DOC PROFESSOR
SWAM SAYS THAT THIS YEAR'S
EVENT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER, GIVEN THE CHALLENGES THAT
THE WORLD IS FACING.
KARA SCHWAB SAYS IT'S CRUCIAL
THAT LEADERS MEET IN PERSON, AS
IT HELPS CREATE TRUST BETWEEN
THEM.
>> --
FALLING APART.
THERE'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF
SYMMETRY, WE NEED TO MANAGE,
AND YOU CAN EXCHANGE SMALL
CIRCLE IDEAS.
YOU CAN TAKE SOME DECISIONS
PARTICULARLY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO BRING THE GLOBAL ECONOMY,
THE GLOBAL STAKEHOLDER COMPANY,
THAT'S IN PERSON AGAIN.
BECAUSE IT'S ONLY WHICH
[INAUDIBLE]
CREATES TRUST, WHICH RECREATES
TRUST.
>> ISN'T THE REALITY, THAT, AND
THAT EVERYTHING THAT DAVOS
STANDS FOR, IS ON THE VERGE OF
FAILURE?
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE, NUMBER ONE,
THE WARREN UKRAINE ALL OF THE
IDEA OF SOME SORT OF COMMON
VIEW ON A EUROPEAN WAY FORWARD,
NUMBER TWO CHINA, UNILATERALLY
SHUT DOWN EVERYBODY ELSE IS
OPEN.
NUMBER THREE, A WERE FAILING ON
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE AND CLIMATE
TARGETS SO WHAT'S THE PURPOSE?
>> FOR DAVOS, THAT'S NEVER BEEN
IMPORTANT AS IT IS NOW.
PARTICULARLY FOR THE REASONS
YOU'VE MENTIONED.
WE CANNOT WIN THE WAR IN
UKRAINE, WE CANNOT TAKE AWAY
COVID AND SO ON, BUT WE CAN
CREATE AND WE CAN COORDINATE
THE RESPONSES TO THOSE
CHALLENGES.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE DOING.
THOSE CHALLENGES NEED THE
COOPERATION OF BUSINESS,
SOCIETY AND OF COURSE MAINLY
POLITICS.
>> RIGHT, SO WHY DID YOU INVITE
RUSSIA?
BECAUSE IF DIALOGUE IS SO
IMPORTANT, WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
BETTER TO HAVE THOSE NON
SANCTION RUSSIANS, ON THE TABLE?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, BUT AT THE END
OF THE DECISION --
ON PUTIN.
AND YOU HAVE SEEN TERRORIST,
MACRON, AND SO ON TRYING TRYING
TO BUILD A BRIDGE.
SO, THE TIME IS NOT YET
[INAUDIBLE]
WE ARE READY, AS SOON AS THE
TIME IS RIGHT.
TO OFFER OUR CAPABILITIES AGAIN.
>> THE BRIDGE BILLING
CAPABILITIES WILL BE IMPORTANT,
YES?
BUT DON'T YOU NEED A MOMENT OF
INTROSPECTION TO ASK HOW DID IT
GO SO WRONG, AND HOW, DAVOS,
WHEN I SAY DAVOS I DON'T MEAN
YOU PERSONALLY, I MEAN THE
COMMUNITY.
YOU SPENT DECADES BRING TRYING
TO BRING RUSSIA INTO THE GLOBAL
COMMUNITY, TO BE PART OF THE
GLOBAL COMMUNITY, ONLY FOR
PRESIDENT PUTIN TO LITERALLY GO
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION?
>> YES, I REGRET IT BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT GLOBAL AFFAIRS, SOME
CERTAIN DEVELOPMENTS GOING --
AND EVEN JAVELINS CANNOT
PREVENT CERTAIN ISSUES FROM NOT
DEVELOPING AS WE WOULD LIKE.
>> IN THAT SENSE IT'S GONNA BE
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE WE'RE
ALL SURRENDERING ECONOMIC GREAT
DIFFICULTIES.
TRULY AWFUL TIMES WE'VE GOT
INFLATION, THE LIKE OF WHICH WE
HAVEN'T SEEN IN YEARS.
>> YES, WE HAVE PART FROM
POLITICAL CONFERENCE WE HAVE A
GLOBAL ECONOMY WHICH IS --
AND WHAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
PARTICULARLY HERE IS THE
CONSEQUENCES.
WE MAY HAVE A LITTLE INFLUENCE
ON HOUSES, HOW DOES I ABOUT A
FUTURE TSAI POLICIES.
WE KNOW THAT IF WE DIDN'T
CHANGE COURSE, WE WILL HAVE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
FALLING BACK INTO POVERTY.
TENS OF MILLIONS PROBABLY DYING
POSSIBLY OF HUNGER.
THIS IS MISSOURI, WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IT, SO IT'S AT THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR TOPIC, OUR
PROGRAM TO GENERATE ACTION.
THAT'S MY INTENTION.
>> THERE'S NEVER BEEN A MORE
IMPORTANT TIME, A MORE SERIOUS
TIME FOR THESE TALKS THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE.
>> YES, [INAUDIBLE]
REFLECTED IN THE MOOD.
IT'S THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
NEEDING I'VE EVER HAD IN THE
LAST 50 YEARS I'D SAY.
AND THE [INAUDIBLE]